SHAMS ZAKHOUR: Hi.
So I've been a Dart
writer at Google
for a little over four years.
And before that, I was a Java
writer for 10 years at Sun
and then four more
years at Oracle.
So when I came to Google,
it was just-- we had just
launched 1.0 of Dart,
maybe a month by the time
I started in mid-December.
And I just felt there was
this lack, this serious lack
of a cute mascot.
I mean, languages
need cute mascots!
So I finally got--
like Duke or Android
or Go, the Gopher.
So I finally got the
go-ahead for this conference
to make a mascot.
So I was working with a
vendor I found in New York,
going back and forth.
And there's a lot
of detail involved
that you might not expect.
We had drawings.
We were going back and
forth on eyes and eyebrows
and how 3-D the tail
was and all this.
And we ended up
with a specification
that I never actually saw,
but I said the size I wanted
and whether it has a tuft
of hair and all this.
So then that was sent off to
a factory, and we got this.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, that might be cute,
but what was interesting
was she sent it
to two factories,
the same specification.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Woo-hoo!
So I like the size of
this one, but come on.
This is cuter.
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
SHAMS ZAKHOUR: Come on.
So this is what we ordered
for this conference.
And I wanted it smaller,
but that would only
happen if we had another
three weeks to do
a prototyping cycle,
which we didn't do.
They weren't
willing to just make
it smaller without a prototype.
So I figured that
once we deplete these,
we can order new ones
at a smaller size.
And then, because you
guys are early adopters,
you'll get a family.
[LAUGHTER]
So if you exit this way, you
can have your Dart plushy.
[CHEERING]